the mostly fluid pattern is very similar
to column drop but it tends to be a bit
more grid like with more columns and
columns fitting in different ways
depending on the viewport width just
like column drop at its narrowest
viewport the layout is stacked but as
the layout gets wider the grid pattern
starts to appear and eventually once the
layout hits its widest viewport margins
are added on the left and right instead
of expanding things out I've made this
one a bit more complex with a few
additional divs just like column drop
I'm using flexbox and setting the width
of each element to 100% at their
narrowest viewport at the first
breakpoint I'll make the light blue div
and the green div 50% width just like
before
I'll add a min width query to check for
a min width of 450 pixels if that's the
case I'll make the light blue and green
50% width
I want another breakpoint at 550 pixels
I'll add the media query and set the
appropriate widths on the right element
and finally a lot of breakpoint that
adds margins to the side when the
viewport is beyond 700 pixels let's take
a look at it in the browser everything
is stacked as I expect it below 450
pixels and as I expand up I get a switch
at 450 I'll get a switch again at 550
pixels and above 700 pixels I'll start
getting margins added to the side that's
exactly what I wanted